water is just such an amazing medium you
can just see the crystals and how they'd
form in so many different ways and then
take that and extrapolate it to these
huge cliffs what we do here is create
spray ice and probably make over 300
different climbs
my name is Alexander Bianchi and I'm a
nice farmer we're down here in the
uncompacted orge we have a water system
at the top of the gorge
these galvanized steel showerheads
and it basically just sprays water out
over the cliffs and overnight when it's
cold it forms ice along the cliffs what
we really want is a nice clean surface
for the new water to come down and just
keep building off of that so a lot of
what we do here actually is to rappel
down a lot of these faces and just try
to clear that snow off ready for the
next layer there's about two miles of
ice if you walk the bottom of the canyon
and yeah we firm ice all on the top of
it the ice farmers kind of hard work
we're gonna open up the South valve
sometimes I think we're no more than
like glorified plumbers
hice timing is our and engineering I
mean the two I think are always really
inseparable
you know the engineering is the
logistics how do we get the water from
point A to point B sometimes if the
valves aren't cracked quiet enough if
you get a little bit of a freeze up the
water stuff you get to develop the
remedy is a blowtorch
we had artistic sizes once we have this
water where we need it how can we do
something different how can we make
something interesting that you know
we've never climbed before it's
definitely an artistic process for some
of us I grew up rock climbing you know
fair-weather climber first time I came
out here was just kind of blown away
it's so different than rock climbing
you're climbing transient mediums the
rock is always going to be there this
this ice is not always there so it
creates this diversity and this intense
experience that I really don't find in
other facets of climbing and that's why
I'm proud to do what I'm doing